You got to work your camera, dude. Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Well, go ahead. You're going to get now
10,000 for every life? Yeah, hey, I'm
going to try to bring them in for you,
man.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm too harsh. I'm not nice. Well, when
you get 54, you're going to be mean like
me. You don't got to be.
You just got to be smooth, have a right
touch of that that aggressiveness, have
a right touch of that smooth calmness,
man. That's that suave, you know what
I'm talking about? Shoot. Exactly. And
you keep You keep doing it. You keep
flexing that. [clears throat] Shoot,
bro. What's up?
But here's what I want you Tell us what
you did today. Tell everybody. Oh, man.
Sam,
I know you don't ever watch my stuff,
but
>> No, I don't want to watch it, man. I'm
old for debates, but I watch your stuff.
>> it would infuriate you. You you would
you would hate listening to it, but
there you would love what I'm doing to
him because
I'm I'm embarrassing him. His his pride
and his arrogance
was was was a tool for me because it was
so bad he kept he kept talking about how
I'm uneducated, I'm not qualified, I
don't have credentials, all of this
stuff. And yet I'm the one telling him
what his tafsir says. I'm the one I'm
catching him on his on him misquoting
the Hadith. I'm catching him on
misquoting verses. He There was this one
golden part where he was talking about
Muhaiman, right? He went to Muhaiman.
Muhaiman ale exactly.
>> Yeah. He said, "Now explain that Explain
Muhaiman." I said, "Well, it depends on
who you ask because according to some of
your tafsir, some said that according to
the verse Muhaiman is the Muhaiman over
the Quran. So, if you're consistent,
you're going to have to say that
Muhammad is an authority over over
Allah's over Allah's revelation." He
said, "No, no, no, no, no, the verse
doesn't say that." So, if now he's doing
now he doesn't want tafsir, he's dealing
with verse. He said I said, "Well, it
depends on who you ask." Depend Here's
So, he said, "Okay, so you you you you
don't want Muhaiman then How about
Furqan?" How about the Furqan?
What what does Furqan mean? I said, "It
means criterion." He mad He He
started LAUGHING ALL LOUD.
>> [laughter]
>> HE'S LOUD HE GOT his boy next to him
Sam. He's laughing loud.
Yeah, see you see you see he said it IS
CRITERION. IT'S CRITERIA AND THE QURAN
IS OUT OF QURAN. I SAID, "Hey guess
what? Guess what? SO IS THE TORAH?"
>> [laughter]
>> YOU KNOW, SO HE'S LIKE AND HIS SMILE
immediately dropped. He said, "Wait
what? What?" I said, "Yeah, the Torah is
also called the criterion in chapter 2
verse 48 chapter 2 verse 53." And so he
I mean he was shook. He did not know
where to go. So
moments like that you'll see clips
coming out. It was an when I I'm saying
it was an absolute outclass dog walk.
I'm not exaggerating because he couldn't
out rhetoric me.
I was [clears throat] able to match and
over match his rhetoric. And also with
my knowledge he couldn't rage bait me. I
held him to the questions. I held him. I
used 1094
I mean and held him to that. Held him to
that. He immediately tried to get away
from that. It was it was it was it was
awesome. And then we talked about the
Trinity on the you know and he and he
couldn't get me there either. So it was
it was fun.
>> where can they watch it?
On my channel. They can watch it on my
channel.
>> So how did it happen on your channel?
What happened?
>> No, so it happened on his channel but
then you know immediately I uploaded it
to my channel right after.
>> Oh, so it you went live to his stream
cuz he calls out people to go to your
stream to his stream. So you went and
did it. Yeah, right there. That that
recent video. Right There you go.
That one right there. Career ended. Let
me guess you got 20,000 watching it live
you sucker. Well, there was there was
six there was 6,000 watching it live.
How many views did it have now? Man,
hater. Shoot. Man, we're barely 300 bro.
I got to go to retirement son. No, you
don't got to go to retirement man cuz
you building me up man. You helping me
out.
>> Well, glory to God may he keep me humble
and you become
the warrior for Christ and you then
teach next generation you stay on fire
young man but
>> Yes sir. I did see Fearless Truth
because I was watching Oh yeah.
>> and he went out it with
What's his name? How do you pronounce
it? I call him Espino.
Uh yeah, uh Flip Flippiano. I call him
Flippiano cuz he always flip-flops. What
happened with that one cuz I there was
Fearless Truth was just watching you? He
was so he was watching while waiting in
the uh in the lobby to to join the
stream.
Um he wanted to talk to to
uh Muhammad next but um Muhammad brought
up Libyano.
He brought up Libyano before bringing up
Nick so cuz he was running from on the
Trinity I destroyed him on the Trinity.
He tried to go the philosophical route
and couldn't get me on the philosophical
route and so destroyed him there.
And so he brought up Libyano
to try to tag him in.
And uh once so once Hajab was done with
the conversation with me I was done with
him. I wasn't talking to that that dog.
Yeah. You can explain to people why you
won't.
Uh I may get a chance he may be
convinced
to do mano e mano with me. So I may get
a chance to go out it with him. So let's
see. Some behind the scenes. We'll see.
I would love to because uh by the power
of the Lord Jesus Christ his career will
end and maybe he'll repent. We'll see
but Yeah. Can you tell people why you
won't deal with him? So they because
it's not because you're running cuz you
had a debate with him and you schooled
him on Jesus being Yahweh. Yep. I
destroyed him on Jesus being the most
high God in the New Testament. He
admitted that Jesus is the most high God
in a sense according to the New
Testament. Um I destroyed him on the
Trinity philosophically on his own
channel. I went to his live and spoke
with him over an hour and um
had a discussion there and even
Jake the Muk Muslim metaphysician
acknowledged that I dog walked him and
using his words
that I dog walked Libyano that he was an
absolute idiot for not knowing certain
terms and concepts that I was presenting
and saying the opposite thing. So,
destroyed him. Already debated him
twice. And then in for for the rest of
that, he's been uh doxing us. He's he's
he's in the crowd of the doxers. So,
like with Malique and so him, he also
doxed um slandered my wife, made a whole
video calling her all type of and
and all this kind of stuff. So, uh he's
someone that will never ever get my
attention. And as much as he begs, he's
a pick-me-sha, is what we call him. A
pick-me-sha. Saying, "Pick me. Pick me."
Well, yeah, no. So, he he won't get my
attention. Now, would you you won't mind
if I if I get a chance to then do it?
And
that's okay
>> Yeah.
If he does it, would you guys because
listen,
the only [clears throat] reason why I do
it is to show this young man that he's
not qualified and send him packing. So,
would you guys be okay if I go after it?
I I I wouldn't mind, man. I mean, I
Yeah, I I I wouldn't mind. It's just not
No, I know you don't you don't need to.
You already schooled him, but
for some reason, they want to take me
out cuz they
want me
to be discredited by this young dude.
And I know he's not on my level. I know,
but you know, what it is. So, if it
happens, I'll do it. But if you say,
"Sam, no, you know what? Forget about
it." I'll I'll respect that. I won't do
it, brother. Yeah, I cuz cuz I he
doesn't deserve our attention off of the
just disgusting things that he's done.
He's a dog.
You know, it's not even it's not even
about the debate anymore. This dude is
personally depraved, you know? And so, I
don't think that anybody should give him
any type of attention and let him rock.
>> Oh, that's good. You done then because
you told me that,
I'm going to
be a man of integrity to show you love,
Yeah. Then
I'm going to have to tell the gentleman
that wanted to set it up, "No can do."
Yeah.
Cool with me.
All right. No, that's all I needed to
hear.
That's all I needed to hear. So, because
again, I'm here publicly, I'm letting
you know
because of my love for this man and
because this man's wife was discredited,
I thought I was just going to go there
and end this career.
But, because when he tells you don't
debate someone, you know that's serious.
Mhm. Cuz he takes them all on. He went
on Muhammad Hijab.
So, you got my word. I'm going to send a
response to this guy say, "Hey, buddy,
I can't do it." So, you guys can say I
ran, I'm scared. Yeah.
>> Can't do it.
All right, you got it. I won't do it,
brother. I won't do it.
Cool.
>> Because so people understand the logic.
God logic, so you pun intended. What he
means is
since this guy has gone the route of
slandering his wife, and I haven't
watched the video, I don't know what he
said, I won't watch it, I won't dignify
it.
And but, you know,
don't watch it, guys. Don't give it
views because curiosity killed the cat.
You're going to go watch it. But, it's
got to be really bad for you to have
this kind of animus cuz people know you,
you go the extra mile of being loving
and kind. Mhm. It's got to be really bad
for you to be disowning cuz I could see
the rage in your face. Yep.
All right, that's it. Out of respect for
you and your wife, I'm not doing it,
brother.
Okay?
Amen. Now, they're going to say I ran to
I, by the way. So, thank you. So, I'm
going to lose more viewers. Thank you,
bros.
>> [snorts]
>> Adam Saleh is going to say you ran, and
too bad. All right, I ran. Okay, I'm a
coward, guys. Okay, Orthodox, Sam
Shamoun exposed Sam Shamoun exposed me.
>> You you've destroyed me. I'm done. So,
for your out of love for you, I won't do
it. Now,
I don't know if you have time. I wanted
to throw these ideas at you cuz you're
just cooking out Joe's Witnesses. Yes.
And I just want to give you two
arguments. You may know it already, so
let me know that. I won't waste your
time, and I'll go and do my thing.
>> as you always say in your sessions, Sam,
we are creatures of repetition.
All right. [snorts] Now, with that said,
>> my pen and everything ready, man.
But, you've been spoken. In fact, tell
them good news. You and Alby
Yes.
>> were live. And on the live stream, what
did a Joe Witness do? The Jehovah's
Witness left the organization and began
questioning everything.
See that?
You guys hear music here is a fact. If
you want to hook up with a guy, this guy
here Lord Jesus Christ reigns he's my
mod. He was a Bethelite.
He worked with the anointed class. He
was high ranking. To be in Bethel,
that's high ranking. That's a
headquarters. This guy here. Mhm. What
the Jehovah's Witness is is a die-hard
Trinitarian on fire for the Trinity.
Unbeknownst to me, he said, "You've been
watching me what? For 10 years?"
Watching us for 10 years. I didn't know
that.
Wow. High ranking, dude. So, Lord Jesus
Christ reigns.
He's someone that you want to get in you
know, hold of. The guy has a mountain of
information cuz he was an insider. He
was in Bethel, their headquarters.
So, but what I wanted to pass on your
way cuz I don't know if you know this.
You I'm not saying you don't. I don't
know if you've used it.
But, when you confront Jehovah's
Witnesses, you need to
ask them what I say need. You probably
do it already. I got to choose my words.
With you, you probably have already done
it. Well, I don't want to talk to me,
man. No, because yeah, I want to be
careful how I talk. I don't want to talk
like I'm the teacher your student cuz
we're all
>> You are. What are you What are you What
I don't want to have disciples, brother.
I'm trying to avoid that, brother.
Because I don't I don't want to say,
"Hey Lord Look, you know, they're my
disciples and I'm responsible for it. I
got a lot to answer for. I don't want to
answer for anyone else."
Okay, so
>> saying?
Whatever, man.
But, here's the thing. Go ahead and
teach me.
Here's the thing.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it froze.
Ah, looks like I'm taking over the live,
ladies and gents.